welcome to the live show ladies and  gentlemen coverage of people who won't  do their jobs those lazy bums get back  to work yeah but look look the Nays the  Democrats are saying they don't want to  leave come on well they want my car no  no no hey the Democrats plus the  holdouts if the if the Republican  holdouts say nay then they ain't going  anywhere so they vote on everything this  is just voting to go home and sleep yeah  you know this is this is the challenging  thing about today this is history yeah  it's the last it was it's been a hundred  years to the day that there has been  something like this well yesterday  when the house did not elect a speaker  100 years 1923 and so here we are again  and Kevin McCarthy has lost six ballots  now they're trying to go home